it's it's fun to delve into the minds of
these coaches especially now that
analytics has become so well accepted
and coaches do the unconventional and
the unconventional has become the
conventional because you've got an
analytics guy who's saying this is what
you should do so the coach can do it and
he's got cover by saying hey that kid
you hired from the wharton school of
business told me to do it it's just it's
fun
every week there's a whole menu of
things we can look at and say did that
go right did that go wrong should you
have done that shouldn't you have done
that and and you know what mike vrabel
is quickly developing a reputation
for a guy who knows the rule book well
he learned well from bill belichick and
he knows where the loopholes are
and
he saved time
late in regulation against the texans by
deliberately
letting the defense have 12 men on the
field and you couldn't really read his
lips because he had his mask on but you
can tell he's telling the defensive
players like what are we doing we got 12
here he's like yeah it's okay don't
worry about it it's okay
and they they
was like wait yeah we got 12 guys here
and we're not supposed to have 12 and
fred was like it's fine it's okay and uh
it was fun because it got the clock
stopped it's it's it's a loophole that
he knows about he's mastered the rule
book and the problem is by taking
advantage of these things chris they're
going to change the rules on of course
they are they are they're going to
change the rules but so what take
advantage of them why you can or when
you need to
and that's what he's done you know in
the end of a few football games over the
last three years you know let alone he
did it to bill belichick in the playoffs
last year i mean pissed bill off who had
pulled it off himself early in the year
against the bragged about itself right
so
uh it just it's again i think the big
thing is rayball has shown us over the
last few weeks that holy cow no matter
how good of a coach you thought he is
he's a better coach and we gave him
credit for for the way they handled
covert 19 and that whole crap and
everything there and to play like they
have played with the limited practice
but just always aware of what's going on
in the football game i mean the way he
talks on a post-game press conference
you know he's just there's never it
doesn't seem to be flustered by anything
and knows the the the tricks of the
trade a little bit and that did that did
save them you know i mean you know
there's a lot of things that happened
after
but regardless it did stop the clock and
give them some extra time
and gave them a chance of course that we
know they really needed that extra time
to get that last touchdown to tie the
game and regulation yeah that drive
would culminate in the texans scoring
the touchdown to put them up by seven
they went for two it kept it a one score
game because they failed and there was
enough time left to go down and tie it
up now i mentioned bill belichick
bragged about it last year when he did
it in garbage time of a monday night
game against the jets and we should have
been happy that he kept the clock
running and running and running and
running because it got the game over
with and put everyone out of their
misery
mike vrabel not inclined to brag about
what he did here he is yesterday when
reporters pressed him on his intentional
violation of the rules in order to
conserve time
question for you on that late uh 12
minute on the on the field penalty
against you guys i guess
uh first question was that you know
intentional potentially done to uh to
stop the clock
um
you know we have to do a better job with
penalties you know we
[Laughter]
a few on had so
you know we have to be be better in all
areas and i think the penalties are one
thing that we focus on
um
you know communicating trying to
trying to give ourselves the best chance
to to win a football game
right but the the 12 men on the field
one in particular uh were you trying to
uh to save some clock time by by getting
that the second one you know just trying
to try to get them to try to make a stop
there and substitute it in
um you know an extra db but
you know we we ultimately
got to do a better job on first down
in four-minute defense and not give up
nine yards
we gotta do a better job on penalties i
think you're doing a pretty good job on
penalties i think i think
yeah i think you i think you figured out
how to make penalties connect to your
objective of winning the game i i think
that's great and it's look the cat's out
of the bag
and i think that's the thing that
probably upsets him more than anything
else that people notice that they're
talking about it and the competition
committee filing away
when we get to the offseason let's
change that rule and make sure the clock
keeps running in a situation like that
but you got to give him credit it's
brilliant whatever the rule book is you
know it inside and out you know when you
can use it to your advantage and you do
it that's
that's what any game
whether it's monopoly
professional football or anything else
if there's a set of rules
that control the game you know them and
you figure out how to use those rules to
your advantage there's nothing wrong
with that at all no nothing wrong with
that don't hate the player hate the game
right that's the old phrase i mean he
didn't he didn't make the rules the way
they are he's following the rules taking
advantage of them a little bit sure yeah
fine but that that's next level stuff it
really is it's second and one i mean
it's so next level he had to like cause
attention to it to make sure the refs
would call the freaking penalty they
like weren't going to call they didn't
realize 12 were on the field at first he
kind of had to make like
a little bit of a scene for them to be
like wait oh there's 12 wait let's stop
the clock they were gonna let the
offense run the damn play and it was a
second and one so he's going they're
gonna run the ball and now i'm gonna
have to burn one of my timeouts or you
know yeah that i'm gonna have to burn
one of my timeouts or i could just do
this and give them the first down
because they're probably going to get it
anyways on a second and one and stop the
clock and maybe that'll make them
because they do need a touchdown on
first down have to want to throw the
ball because they're they are you know
houston was in a position where they
wanted to score
and tie the football game so you know
for or go ahead in the football game i'm
sorry but that that was awesome and it
really was
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports